the problem
already discussed don't need to uh
belittle sort of be label that belabor
that is the correct word
so here's all the solutions that I
implemented and I watch so many podcasts
I hired a a sleep expert spent three
thousand dollars on this guy for several
weeks of uh consults and coaching
read books on it podcast after podcasts
shorts after clip after clip all this
stuff this is everything that I found
and I'm going to tell you what was most
effective for me and a lot of these kind
of have a synergistic sort of Compound
Effect if I'm being honest
um first thing that you got to know is
that a lot of what we're dealing with
today that interrupts sleep patterns
noise
light pollution [ __ ] EMF around us
all the time these are all things that
you have a certain degree of control of
and it's not that expensive to fix these
like some of these solutions that I'm
going to talk to you about in this video
um look if you're older you got your
money sorted you're not going to care
about you're going to go and spend it
trust me it will help but some of these
are pretty much free like dark cold and
quiet uh dark cold and quiet shouldn't
cost you that much money to fix
um we didn't have light pollution or any
light whatsoever
1000 years ago right Candlelight maybe
if you're lucky or a campfire but that
was it we're designed to sleep in the
dark absolute Darkness uh with the
exception of maybe some light from the
moon and stars pretty much absolute
Darkness so make your room like a bat
cave you shouldn't be able to see your
hand in front of your face like it
should be that dark
um if you have a set of blinds or
shutters or California shutters go to a
store I know Costco shell sells blackout
curtains they're not expensive get
blackout curtains they also deaden sound
too so they're and you know in the
summertime if it's hot they also keep
heat out of the
um room as well too so blackout curtains
are probably the best bang for your buck
it's it's going to make your own your
room dark it's going to make your room
cold it's going to make it quieter so if
there's Street noise it's going to
filter out some of that so make your
room as cold dark and quiet as possible
when I say cold doesn't have to be a
fridge but apparently the ideal
temperature sleep in is somewhere around
17 degrees Celsius I don't know what
that is in Fahrenheit probably 65 to 67
something like that maybe 66. about 65
it's you know let's call it uh you want
to get the temperature cooler right
because it gets cold at night and it's
unnatural to be in a bed during the day
that's 20 degrees and 20 degrees at
night because your HVAC is on and you
keep the heat on super high at night
it's unnecessary and it's not good for
deep restful sleep you're going to get
deeper restful more continuous sleep if
your room is cold dark and quiet
eliminate noise if you've got look
there's some things you can't do to get
rid of noise noisy neighbors Street
noise you live in a noisy City you can
get earplugs one of the things that I
found incredibly frustrating when I was
trying to fix my sleep issues is I put
all the work into cold dark and quiet
room you know blackout curtains I even
change the windows around my bedroom
um because I didn't find them to keep
the keep the street noise out if you
will so I I just paid for better Windows
I mean the windows were about 10 15
years old anyway and probably needed to
get replaced at some point but I just
put in new windows that were that were
deeper and had sound deadening
properties to them
um and again one of the things I found
incredibly frustrating is you know when
I was doing the dating and the plates
and all that sort of stuff you'd be
usually downtown there's a lot of city
lights in Toronto [ __ ] noise and
sirens and all this and like chicks
don't have proper blinds in their
bedroom it's like horrible you're gonna
have terrible sleep
um set up your set up your sleep Studio
your bedroom whatever you want to call
it so it is cold dark and as quiet as
possible you can use a sleep mask to
cover your eyes you can use earplugs for
your ears if necessary uh and definitely
lower the temperature so that's that's
step one
um and again you guys in the chat or in
the uh comments after this leave you
know leave whatever your tips are but
just sit tight because they're probably
going to cover most of them
um the other thing is removing stress so
one of the problems that I had was
um when I went whenever I had stress in
my life I would always wake up somewhere
between two and three a.m which by the
way is also uh Peak cortisol production
time when you're stressed so if you find
yourself in a position where you find
yourself getting up two to three o'clock
in the morning and you can't fall back
asleep that's because your cortisol is
generally spiking
um you've got to remove as much stress
from your life as possible you don't
have control over a lot of things in
your life there's only one part of the
universe that you can control and that's
yourself and that is what you should
focus on
um I had somebody that once gave me a
tip because you know I was talking to
him about
um you know dealing with stress you know
female betrayal trick chick you know
chicks will cheat on you of course and
you wake up in the middle of the night
you're like oh what did I do was this me
what could I have done better blah blah
blah you're lying there like a goofball
trying to figure it out trying to replay
events in your mind like a [ __ ] because
that's what we do and we're plugged in
guys right and dude was like just just
take you know just take your ideas just
take a pen and write it down he goes you
know whatever's in your head just
download it go through the exercises
just writing it down and I had one of
these funky uh pens I don't have it here
anymore but I had this pen that actually
had a light right in the tip of the pen
left that in the bedroom and you know
you click it on the light would come on
so you can see the paper and you can see
what you're writing I never really
looked at it but I would just you know
write down [ __ ] and it was hilarious
because by the time you'd wake up in the
morning you look at that notepad you'd
see things like you [ __ ] you betrayer
like you know just like the weirdest
sort of things but that that in itself
might be therapeutic for for some guys
but ultimately you have to eliminate and
learn how to give fewer [ __ ] about
things that aren't truly fuckworthy that
aren't within your realm of control
there's a chapter in my book about
managing your [ __ ]
um in the unplugged Alpha I know many of
you guys have read it
um you can Chris grab it off of Amazon
or Kindle or whatever
um you know but I talk about some of
those details in there but you have to
manage stress and remove it as much as
possible there's a lot of things like
exercise I'm going to talk about you
know like a few of those other
components that help to reduce stress as
well and some supplementation but stress
is stress is a killer if you find
yourself getting up between two and
three a.m it's usually because of
cortisol spiking and that's a result of
stress it ain't worth it it's it's it's
good like you keep doing that for years
it will take time off the end of your
life you will live a shorter life a less
productive and a less fulfilled and a
less optimized life if you let stress
get to you if that's a problem for you
do whatever you can to minimize stress
eliminate it and do everything you can
to get more restful and deeper sleep
three four five hours doesn't cut it
that's [ __ ] it's it's not going to
work another thing that you got to do is
remove screens from your life so if
you've got
I mean we all have these devices in our
hands all the time uh whether it's
tablets TVs or whatever but they all
emit blue light
and most of them in the settings like I
know my Android has
um
a screen setting where you can take out
blue light at night time turn that on so
that it so that it removes as much blue
light as possible
you see a lot of these um biohacking
dudes right and I'll be honest I'm a
little bit of a biohacker I don't tell
anybody you know but I've I've figured
out what works and what doesn't work but
a lot of these guys will have like these
blue blocking glasses and they have like
yellow tints to them sort of thing those
things you know can work as well to
eliminate it but the best thing really
is not to look at screens before bed
um I can't tell you how many people
you know have TVs or phones or tablets
right in their bedroom either on the
wall or at their bedside table almost at
all times and it's a really really
really bad idea
um when I get ready for bed like this is
my workstation this is where the EMF is
the computer screens the lights the
Wi-Fi all that [ __ ] I leave
everything here everything is like you
know if I'm going to bed the phone's
here plugged into charge here you know
and it's charging cord sort of thing
um I don't bring my phone in my bedroom
I don't [ __ ] care about notifications
they're all off the phone is on silent I
don't care if somebody dies in the
middle of the night I can't do [ __ ]
about it I'll deal with it in the
morning when I wake up I don't need to
get emergency calls
um it's not important to me sleep is
more important to me phone's plugged in
it's on mute and it's away from my body
uh using screens
before bed or around bedtime or waking
up to them like some people check their
phones in the middle of the night again
you know
um you know plate spinning days a lot of
women keep phones in their bedroom right
by their bedside table or they'll be on
them in the middle of [ __ ] night
glowing like on their faces like you
know it's like [ __ ] you know you're not
designed to do that when you when it
gets dark and you get sleepy and it's
cool
go to sleep and get rid of anything
that's a distraction that distracts you
from deep sleep another thing that I'd
recommend here and I got my notepad over
here and a few things going to pop up
there's an app here uh here I'll put up
on the screen I'm going to show you how
it works because it's actually really
cool and it's free
um if I go you'll probably see this on
my screen actually if I do it this way
um
let's go here to slides
okay no share screen here we go
window boom so on the bottom of the
screen over here if I just highlight
this does it show it doesn't show it up
does it
hang on let's see if there's a way that
I can get that to show up
maybe it won't show it up because it's
stream yard
I might just have to explain it to you
sorry try Chrome tab see if it pops up
that way
and full screen let's try that
I said no it doesn't
okay so this isn't going to show on the
screen because it's because it's a above
the show sort of application stream yard
doesn't let me pop it up but there's an
app that you can get for absolutely free
called f dot Lux okay f is in Frank dot
l u x as an x-ray you should have this
on all of your devices uh that you can
put it on it goes on PCS it goes on iOS
devices tablets
um actually don't quote me on that I'm
not sure about tablets but laptops and
desktops
um and what it does is you set your
location and it and it follows your time
zone right right here right now in the
bottom right it's got my GPS location
I'm not going to read it out for obvious
reasons but
um it's got my GPS location and it knows
what time the sun comes up what time the
sun comes down at that location and then
what it starts to do is during the day
it has full blue light coming out of the
screen by around 7 30 o'clock or so it
seems on this setting it starts to take
out about half the light half the blue
light and by
um 9 30 10 o'clock it's it's completely
off the screen there's very very very
little blue light and that kind of makes
the screen look awkward it makes it look
almost like yellowish a lot of the
brightness is gone it's kind of annoying
you know if you're looking for a bright
screen but what it does is it takes out
a lot of the blue light and the blue
light is is what messes with circadian
rhythm uh and it's it's going to
interrupt your sleep pattern so stop
using the damn screens keep them out of
the bedroom don't fall asleep the TVs
you shouldn't even have a TV in your
bedroom I'll talk about EMF in a minute
use f dot Lux to take out the blue light
use the settings on your phones to take
out blue light at night that will
improve your body's ability to produce
melatonin get into deep restful sleep
and stay asleep throughout the night you
also should stay consistent one of the
great tragedies for us is that a lot of
people
Monday to Friday it's they have a
schedule they get up they do their stuff
they go to work they come home they do
their stuff they go to sleep and they
generally go to sleep earlier during the
week than they do on the weekends and
then it's like Friday and it's like
woohoo it's party time or Saturday and
it's like they stay out to like the wee
hours of the night and they they don't
get enough sleep they don't get enough
quality sleep and then by the time
Monday rolls around they're tired of
[ __ ] and that's why they're all it's
Monday
for me personally I just sleep exactly
the same time pretty much seven days a
week I don't give a [ __ ] I could be out
at a party at a retreat at whatever and
if it's like 10 o'clock and I usually
start feeling tired by like 9 30 10
o'clock I'm like yo peace out I'm going
to bed and some people give you a hard
time over that what do you do and have a
few more drinks drink drink drink shot
shot shot blah blah blah smoke a dude
it's like no I'm going to sleep I don't
give a [ __ ] you guys keep partying I'll
see you all in the morning right and I
always like get my room away from all
the hustle bustle and noise and [ __ ]
that's just the way that I am because I
don't give a [ __ ] for me sleep is more
important and staying consistent with
when you get up and when you go to sleep
seven days a week is far better than you
know five days a week and then your body
has to try to adapt to like two days of
like very little sleep or late sleep and
trying to sleep in which you really
can't do because your body's not used to
it so being consistent with your sleep
patterns is by far the best way to get
get again deep restful quality sort of
sleep
another recommendation that I would make
for you guys is getting a Wi-Fi timer
now I'm going to get into some deeper
kind of like wusah [ __ ] at this time
because getting rid of all EMF in your
room and my view is helpful there's a
lot of studies that have indicated that
being around EMF
these these frequencies and that's by
the way that's like
electronic frequencies through wires in
the wall That's Bluetooth that's Wi-Fi
that's cellular signals you can get rid
of a lot of these you know by the way
um I mean there's nothing you can really
do about Wi-Fi About Cellular signals or
your neighbor's Wi-Fi for example but
that mostly stays in their house it
doesn't you know come in your house
especially if you've got distance you
know between the two places but EMF is
disruptive to mitochondrial function and
especially mitochondrial function in
your nuts and if you want strong
testosterone levels having like putting
a cell phone in your pocket by your
balls is a bad idea that's a dumb ass
it's about the dumbest thing that you
can do and sleeping by your cell phone
is a really bad idea having Electronics
in your room is a really bad idea some
people will
um you know will just limit it down to
like lamps you know for example if they
have bedside lamps and I'm going to get
geeky on you here but the fact of the
matter is is well let me explain it to
you this way if you have a garden hose
and the water pressure is on but the
sprayer is off like you're not pulling
the trigger there's pressure up until
that point until you until you squeeze
the trigger electricity works the same
way even if the lamp is off if it's
right by your bed there's electrical
current coming right up to the switch
where you turn the knob to let you know
to turn on the light and turn off the
light so there's still current that
comes close to your body
um one of the most interesting
biohackers that I knew he when he custom
built his house he actually set up his
bedroom so it had a master kill switch
on the outside of the bedroom so before
you'd come into the room there was a
switch on the outside of the wall which
would kill uh electrical feed to all the
outlets and sockets throughout the room
with the exception of the one that he
needed for his chili pad I'll talk about
the chili pad later but basically
everything in the room didn't have any
electrical current going through the
walls through the lamp plugs uh the
lighting the fans nothing it was it was
a complete Dead Zone that's a little bit
extreme and for you to do that you'd
really have to like get to that point
when you're building the house uh but
just having a Wi-Fi timer that kills the
Wi-Fi in your house after a certain
period of time because you're not using
Wi-Fi when you're sleeping so why have
that [ __ ] bouncing around your house in
the middle night when you're trying to
sleep it's not normal it's not natural
EMF disrupts sleep uh it disrupts your
mitochondrial function you know your
body especially in your nuts and stuff
like that get rid of anything that's
electronic in your room I know that's
going to piss some people off but I
can't sleep without the TV on and blah
blah blah you'll get used to it trust me
um I used to have a TV in my room and
I'd often you know leave it on or on a
sleep timer to fall asleep to it uh it
doesn't matter I don't even notice the
difference in fact I sleep better and I
fall asleep faster without having a TV
or any kind of electronics in my room I
don't even have a lamp by my bedside
table
um the lamps on the other side of the
room so like there's very very little of
anything with the exception of my chili
pad and a CPAP which I'll get into in a
little bit hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out